hey E.T come see me in my new movie
reindeer games this Christmas 1999 right
before uh the world ends with the Y2K
people don't take the Y2K seriously I do
and my entire life
is literally locked into some little
Palm Pilot
so in this thing when this thing all
blows up I it's gonna be just like a
virtual Amnesia New Year's 1999 will be
the interesting time yes 3-0
who programmed your computer on Aztec
and the vatican's doing we're in
business the Millennium uh I'm gonna sit
in my house and protect it from crazy
spiritual Freaks and looters and
pillagers and that's about it this would
be the New Year's to go out the year
2000 I'm not going out I'll be in the
bunker with the saltines and the water
and a little bit of extra cash if you
know what I'm saying it's going to be
Mad Max territory don't you agree well
I'm going to be sitting on my porch with
a shotgun and a jug of water
[Music]
friends can Party Like It's 1999 this
year next year we're all partying
like it's you know
survivalist Camp that's all I'm saying
just a quick little warning to the
Entertainment Tonight viewers very much
it'll be me Tash a couple other people
hunkering down
well I'm again I don't know it's
ironically like the year the dragon
right I kind of was thinking like a
dragon was going to come flying out the
air busting out of the Times Square so I
don't know hopefully you know some girls
will show some thongs or something
all right if there's two things you do
before I'm again do what you got to do
and then come see Randy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]